and this will be the second video in the
series of beta-oxidation
in the first video we talked about how
the free fatty acids are transported
from adipose tissue to the target cells
where they are metabolized we also
talked about how the free fatty acids
enter into the cytoplasm and the
mitochondria now in this video we will
be talking about the oxidative
catabolism of fatty acids that takes
place inside the mitochondrial matrix
now let us talk about what happens in
the mitochondrial matrix which is the
complex part of the beta oxidation what
you're seeing is the basic formula of a
fatty acid in which our side chain is
attached to the carboxyl functional
group in this compound if we remove the
hydrogen atom and attach a co-ed group
to this compound this becomes a fatty
acyl coa the word party in the named
party ISIL co a can be replaced
depending upon the length of the side
chain that is attached to the functional
group for example a side chain with 16
carbons the fatty acid will be called
Palmetto Elk away and a party acid with
a side chain of 14 carbons will be
called nearest oil Co a and twelve
carbons will be called loriel co a when
this fatty acyl Kawai enters into the
matrix of the mitochondria by the
carnitine shuttle mechanism it is acted
upon by four enzymes
whose main job is to remove two carbon
atoms from the parent fatty acid now
these reactions lead through generation
of two molecules one is the acetyl co a
and the second molecule is a new fatty
acyl co a which is two carbons shorter
than the original parent fatty acid
which in this case will be a 14 carbon
compound called merest oil Kawai now the
cool part about this beta oxidation
pathway is that the newly formed fatty
acyl qwave which is 2 carbon less than
the parent compound reenters this
pathway so now we begin with a 14 carbon
compound the mistral Kawai this
acted upon by the same enzymes and this
leads to a generation of a new fatty
acid which is 12 carbon compound fatty
acid this also leads to generation of a
new molecule of acetyl co a with every
cycle of with oxidation the fatty acid
side chain gets shorter and palmitoyl
koel when completely metabolized by
these four enzymes
gives rise to 8 molecules of acetyl co a
now let's look at how a 16 carbon fatty
acid the palmitoyl co a is broken down
completely into 8 molecules of acetyl co
a through the process of beta oxidation
in mitochondrial matrix so we begin this
example with the 16 carbon fatty acid
which is called palmetto L Co a you can
see the Alpha and the beta carbons of
this fatty acid the first reaction that
takes place in the series of beta
oxidation is a dehydrogenation reaction
which means removal of hydrogen hydrogen
atoms are removed along the beta and the
alpha carbons which causes a formation
of a double bond between them the
compound that is produced is called
trans in oil co a and the enzyme that
catalyzes this reaction is called
si Alcoa T hydrogenous
you can see clearly that the hydrogen
atoms are removed from the alpha and
beta carbons and these hydrogen atoms
are then donated to the electron
acceptor which in this case will be the
fa D which is reduced to fadh2 the
resultant molecule is called trans in
Olof because the two hydrogen atoms are
now in trance State
the second reaction that takes place in
the series of wheat oxidation is the
hydration reaction which means addition
of water water is added around the Alpha
and the beta carbons a hydroxyl group is
added to the beta carbon and a hydrogen
atom around the alpha carbon and the
compound produced is called hydroxy fil
Co a and the enzyme involved is anoying
co a hydratase the third reaction
involved is again a dehydrogenation
reaction hydrogen is removed from the
beta carbon of hydroxy as il co a which
causes the formation of a double bond
between carbon and oxygen atom the
hydrogen removed is accepted in this
case by nad which is reduced to NADH and
this reaction is catalyzed by the enzyme
hydroxy assign KOed dehydrogenase and
the compound produced is called keto si
el Cucuy
the key to Elko a is a much more
symmetric and balanced molecule which
can be broken down into two molecules so
the last reaction involved is a cleavage
reaction all dialysis this reaction also
uses a molecule of coenzyme a and it is
catalyzed by the enzyme thiolase
the key to ISIL ko is then broken down
into two molecules the first is a new
fatty acid which has a sidechain of 14
carbons called Mary Stojko a and the
second molecule is a acetyl co a take a
closer look at this reaction and try to
understand how the key to assign Co a is
broken down into these two molecules
the first three reactions involved in
the series of beta-oxidation just
prepare the party si lqa to a more
balanced and symmetric molecule which
can be broken down into two molecules
the metal oil co you produce again
enters the series of with oxidation and
it is completely utilized to form eight
molecules of Estill Co ed through the
similar reactions
about the summary and the energy yield
of beta oxidation up in now we have
studied how a 16 carbon palmitoyl co a
is converted into eight molecules of
acetyl co a in these reactions we have
also seen reducing equivalents are
produced that is the fadh2 and the nadh
a 4 a 16 carbon fatty acid the Palmetto
oil co a to be completely broken down
into eight molecules of acetyl co a it
has to undergo seven cycles of beta
oxidation during this seven cycle of the
beta oxidation a four carbon sidechain
is left which is completely broken down
into two molecules of acetyl CoA
so after seven cycles of wit oxidation
we have the following products we have
eight molecules of vegetal Kawai we have
seven molecules of NADH and we have
seven molecules or fadh2 all these
reactions takes place in the
mitochondria so we have the enzymes of
Krebs cycle and electron transport chain
in close proximity where all of these
substrates can be utilized for the
calculation of energy eight molecules of
acetyl co e are spread to the Krebs
cycle the seven molecules of nadh and
fadh2 are fed to the electron transport
chain for the production of energy now
for calculation of how many ATP's are
produced during the beta oxidation you
should know one molecule of acetyl co a
gets ten ATP's through the one cycle of
Krebs cycle
make sure to watch the video in clear
cycle for better understanding of this
topic
one molecule of NADH is equivalent to
three ATP's and one molecule of fadh2
through electron transport chain gives
two ATP's but this is really the
situation because not all of the time or
the substrate is utilized in the
electron transport chain and also small
amount of energy is also lost in
transport and carrier proteins so for
energy calculation we take one NADH is
2.5 ATP's and one molecule of fadh2
equivalent to 1.5 ATP's so coming to the
energy yield of beta oxidation of
pomodoro a 8 molecules of acetyl co a
will give 80 ATP's through kreb cycle 7
molecules of NADH will give 17.5 ATP's
through electron transport chain and
similarly 7 molecular fadh2 will give
10.5 ATP's through the electron
transport chain
in total we have 180 PS
from this it is essential to deduct two
ATP's which are utilized in the
activation of Palmetto elk away so the
energy healed through our 16 carbon
fatty acid is 106 atps per molecule of
Palmetto elk away so this was all about
the process of beta oxidation thank you
so much for watching this video like our
channel on YouTube for all the upcoming
videos and make sure to LIKE our channel
on Facebook for flash cards and upcoming
notifications